this week microsoft and tesla announced
major new layoffs joining a growing
number of companies that are cutting
jobs or saying they're going to slow
hiring more than 30 000 layoffs
nationwide in the month of june that's
up nearly 60 percent from a year earlier
and many fear that more layoffs could be
coming amid concerns about a possible
recession linkedin career expert
catherine fisher joins us now with
advice on how to bounce back if you lose
your job catherine thank you for being
here so for those people who have
already lost their job or who are afraid
that in the months ahead they will what
do they do to get their house in order
so you know regardless of the job market
you should always be prepared so the
first thing is you know make sure that
you're tending to your network and what
i mean by that is think about it like
gardening you plant the seeds you don't
just you know
ignore it for three years make sure
you're out there talking to your network
it doesn't mean you have to go out to
dinner every week join the conversations
that they're having participate check in
on people that's really important
because you're going to need to rely on
that community that you've built over
the years to help you if you need a job
and if that calendar notification has
come up and hr wants to see you at 9am
the next day and then you get the little
packets slid across the table yes what
do you do then what do you do well first
it's it's okay to be upset i mean this
is an upsetting time if this happens to
you so take that moment take the the you
know the days that you need to prepare
but when you go out into the job market
make sure that you are positive that
you're really leaning into that network
of yours that you are signaling to
people that you're open to work the good
news is that this stigma has really
changed and there's actually tools on
linkedin to be able to notify recruiters
if you're open to work and if you're
comfortable to your broader network you
can also what we're seeing is people are
sharing this on linkedin so they are
talking about you know i've been laid
off what how can you help me
and i think it's really important that
people start leaning into this wow the
stigma really is changing there is that
image of like the pink slip right but
people are talking about it openly as
they should you know this is just part
of the economy part of life
unfortunately
but for people who you know might be in
a position where you know they were laid
off what industries are hiring right now
right well and this is one thing i do
want to point out is layoffs are
happening but you know hiring is still
happening and so we see you know the
healthcare industry farming forestry
education those industries are hiring
and the south is also having a surge of
hiring so dallas houston's st louis
those places are there's lots of jobs
there um you're so right about the
stigma around layoffs uh i remember i
got laid off in
almost 10 years ago and you get that
little your job has been negatively
impacted thing and i felt a lot of shame
about it you know you feel like oh if
i'd done a better job it would have
worked out differently uh but now people
talk about it online that they're very
open about it are there any guidelines
or things to look out for about being
open about it or just share it all you
know i think what you want to do is be
positive so
what you know try to avoid
lambasting the company that you came
from really be positive and share with
your network what you're looking for so
we um actually you know the we've seen a
lot of people posting this and what's
really wonderful to see in the comments
is people saying hey listen i know of a
job here send me you know i'm going to
message you i'm going to you know
introduce you to this person so being
really clear about what it is that
you're looking for is important to share
and and it is like like i said you
should you know it's okay to be upset
just you want to appear to be
professional do you want to appear
save the real talk for offline yeah it's
like when you're making friends and the
friend of yours gossips about someone
else you're like okay well what are you
saying about me when i'm not here
and that's what employers are looking
for are you seeing a lot of anxiety
right now on linkedin in conversations
because of this yeah you know we
actually did a poll and we asked our
members what what they thought of
layoffs and 37
said that they
were concerned about layoffs 38 said
yeah we think layoffs are coming but
it's not going to happen to me and 22
said no and what was really interesting
though was the conversation happening so
one person pointing out listen it's
these big name companies that have been
doing these layoffs but if you look at
the larger scheme of things it's okay
well thank you so much for all these
tips catherine fisher thanks so much